[Music]
foreign you are watching The Press
preview of first look at what's on the
front pages as they arrive in the next
half hour we'll see what's making the
headlines with journalist and author
Christina Patterson and columnist at the
article Ali Mirage so let's see what's
on some of those front pages for you now
well the Sunday Express says 100 MPS are
plotting to remove the prime minister
that also makes the front of the
Observer which says a plan to bring in a
so-called Unity candidate has been
dubbed a rescue mission
that Unity candidate could be defense
secretary Ben Wallace that's according
to the Sunday Mirror
but while this trust is still at number
10 it's Jeremy Hunt who holds the Reigns
of power says the Sunday Times
the Sunday Telegraph reports that the
new Chancellor is considering delaying a
1p tax cut and has won the backing of
the bank of England
and the Daily Star Sunday says Shane
McGowan from The Pogues has a fear of
fairies
not quite sure why that's news but
anyway a reminder that by scanning the
QR code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's newspapers while you
watch us
and we are joined tonight by Christina
Patterson and Ali Mirage welcome to you
both good evening let us start with the
expres and their headline in a bold
letters revealed a secret plot to oust
PM I would suggest that it's not so
secret to anymore Christina
yeah well exactly I mean these plots
have been circulating in the papers for
days on end so as you say not exactly
the usual definition of secrecy I mean I
have to say having inflicted this
absolute catastrophe on our country the
hubris of the Tory party that they now
think oh we can just you know have a
little chat among ourselves and sort
this out and submit to the country to
whoever we think we should foist on them
next it's just I mean it's just a
breathtaking actually absolutely
breathtaking they put us through this
catastrophe and we are talking
catastrophe I don't know anyone at the
moment who isn't worried about their
personal finances including people like
doctors who've never worried about their
finances particularly in their life if
people who are on earning considerably
more than the uh national average are
worried then Heaven Help the rest of us
this is uh I mean it is the
the idea that
that comes to think oh now we think
we'll have zones so no perhaps we should
have zones so the idea of a Unity
candidate is for the birds because we
have never ever seen a party so striven
with Rife and factions and fighting as
this lot of charlatans who've inflicted
this chaos in our country clearly we
need a general election yesterday
um an investor at Harvey's land and said
that the only thing that would calm the
bond markets at this point was a general
election we don't need the chairs being
moved on the Titanic the Titanic is
already sinking we need an absolute
change to this country and I wish that
the Tories party for once would put the
country before their own vested
interests because it is absolutely
disgraceful what they're doing for for
us and they should never be forgiven for
it never be forgiveness
for a long time Ali do you agree that
that a change of candidate is is not the
the answer that that really is as
Christina says you know rearranging the
the the the deck chairs on the Titanic
well look Julian uh I'm a great lover of
Christmas
um but I hadn't realized the pantomime
season had already started uh we are in
a really really deeply worrying and
unfortunate situation here uh I've known
Liz truss uh personally for over 20
years
um she's always had very warm and
cordial relations with me and vice versa
but I just make this appeal that look
the entire program on which Liz stood on
has been utterly and completely
discredited uh her policies have been
jettisoned and thrown overboard one by
one she now has a new Chancellor in
place that has reversed this pledge to
keep corporation tax at 19 and not
increase it everything that Rishi sunak
said he was the other candidate in the
Tory leadership has come to pass he said
that the pound would be put under
pressure he said that boring would cost
would go up that people's mortgages
would be affected it's exactly as he
outlined Liz has to go unfortunately
this should not be dragged out
um Christina's calling for an election I
personally think that there potentially
should be an election although frankly I
don't think the labor party have
actually got any policies I mean you
could argue they don't need any K storm
is already looking Prime ministerial
just by actually looking articulate at
the dispatch box that may be the case
but look turkeys don't vote for
Christmas uh sorry to keep my Christmas
analogy going but Tory MPS are not going
to vote for are not going to go for a
general election now particularly when
they know that they're going to lose
their seats the
the game for them is to try and minimize
the loss what they really need to do is
Liz needs to go she needs to do The
Honorable decent thing now and just go
they need to put someone in place
quickly that person in my view has to be
rich you have to declare an interest I
voted for issue because I thought he was
the most sensible guy but I don't say it
because I voted for her I just don't
think that Ben Wallace which is being
touted at the moment has got that
mandate because he didn't put himself
forward in that leadership contest he
could have done but he didn't so I think
Rishi now has been Vindicated I think
it's up to if they have to go to Rishi
you might say no you might say like I'm
happy to hang out in Yorkshire you had
your chance you blew it but look parties
sometimes make mistakes uh the labor
Party voter for Jeremy corbyn the Tories
waiting for Ian Duncan Smith in in the
early 2000s at parties do you make
mistakes
today that regarding the economy that
mistakes were made I just want to
quickly we're going to move on to the
Observer but quickly get this thought
that's raised in the express that uh
kwesi quateng had actually argued
against uh Mr truss's plan to cut taxes
for the world healthiest in the mini
budget so um he wasn't completely in
agreement with her and it was her that
was pushing it Forward according to uh
the express Christina very quickly
yeah well I I wouldn't be at all
surprised by that and I think her her
disloyalty is is utterly breathtaking I
mean people keep using this weird phrase
lockstep that the two of them are being
in lockstep over this whole thing and we
know that it was they had a pretty you
know pretty unified Vision which
basically meant you know cutting taxes
for the rich and uh and stuffing
everybody else but uh but the fact that
um even quasi-quarting resisted cutting
taxes for the very very rich I I'm not
surprised by that and I think that she
has behaved appallingly I mean she
didn't even give a reason for him for
having sex sacked him because it was her
policy she very he very clearly
implemented and she just said that she
um accepted essentially him being knifed
in the back when she had knifed him in
the back the whole thing is surreal she
has put us through an absolute Nightmare
and um I think I wouldn't I wouldn't
blame quasi-quarting I mean I think he's
behaved appallingly he's been utterly
incompetent careless and has gone around
talking about a little turbulence When
people's futures have been and their
hopes of buying a house have been wiped
out but I I agree that it's not fair for
him to take the rap for this just to get
my thought just again I thought Ali you
said you'd uh voted for a Liz truss um
in the Observer just no I won't give a
Rishi I'm sorry sorry in The Observer an
MP just being quoted as saying it would
be grotesque to allow trust to endure
another appearance at Prime Minister's
questions in the Commons on Wednesday
after a series of humiliating u-turns do
you think that she might be uh ejected
before Wednesday even this week
this coming week well look I I honestly
I honestly think she needs to resign I
think that is the most decent and
honorable way out of this mess uh before
she's pushed I mean who wants to see
this unedifying spectacle dragged out
any longer and their country doesn't
need this and the other thing is I mean
if you look at some of the supply side
reforms that she has been uh proposing
planning reform that's not going to go
anywhere a lot of shy Tories are going
to be completely up in arms against that
you remember the algorithm when Boris
Johnson had that ATC majority didn't go
anywhere it's hardly going to go
anywhere now and you look at immigration
she wants to uh sort of open and have a
more liberal immigration policy that may
be very sensible but certainly again
you've got her an odds with swelling
problem and her own Home Secretary who's
saying that she wants to reduce
immigration to the tens of thousands so
even on the supply side I can't see
these reforms going through Jeremy Hunt
now is the most powerful man in the
government he's the one who's now trying
to put things on an even Keel he's at
one with Andrew Bailey Andrew Betty's
come out and said that what's being
suggested now is sensible yes
the governor of the bank of England
described it as uh Ali and Christina for
the moment thank you we are going to
take a break coming up
uh much more including this story in the
telegraph their headline reads John
Major attacks the crown as malicious
nonsense stay with us more on that
[Music]
welcome back you're watching the Press
preview still with me journalist and
author Christina Patterson and columnist
at the article Ali Mirage let's have a
look at the Observer first of all and
the story there it's that the warrior of
unions that there might be this new era
of austerity as a hinted at by the new
Chancellor Christina take us into this
story
yes well the unions understandably are
extremely worried I mean the TUC
represents 48 unions that represent five
and a half million workers uh the the
main teaching Union is worried Unison is
worried all the unions are worried
because nobody voted for austerity when
Boris Johnson was elected in 2019 he ran
on a ticket of basically I'm going to
throw money at everything and brexit's
going to be marvelous and everything's
going to be wonderful now obviously he
couldn't have foreseen the war in
Ukraine and that has led to issues
globally but what we are looking at now
is has is not to do with that I mean
there would be an increase in interest
rates which would be
um affiliated with that and of course
energy price Rises but the reason we are
going through this particular crisis is
because of unfunded and totally
unnecessary tax cuts which we now hear
according to the obr are leaving a 72
billion hole in our budget that is
unbelievable and the net results Jeremy
Hunt is saying and it's hard to see
where the money is going to come to fill
that hole because the blizzatras's utter
breathtaking and actually criminal
carelessness is that ordinary working
people on top of having to pay higher
mortgages higher rents higher prices for
their Foods higher energy bills and also
fund those the subsidy for rich people's
energy bills for years if not decades to
come let's just bring that Ali and
Christina because we are running out of
time um obviously we don't know where uh
these these cuts are coming from but the
chancellor has promised a very difficult
decisions to be made by the government
Ali
well look I look at real wages for uh
key workers have been in many cases
falling for the best part of a decade so
there is a serious problem in terms of
paying many parts of the public sector
that needs to be looked at I mean the
reality is that governments can only do
one to one of three things in this kind
of situation where where public finances
are under pressure they can tax you they
can borrow or they can cut spending I
mean borrowing at the moment you see the
markets they don't believe that the
boring plans are sustainable in their
current form you need to trim somewhere
but it is going to be very painful and I
don't think the public sector clearly is
going to be very amenable to this at all
I can fully understand why but I also
think that the um the the increase in
National Insurance should have just
remained I mean we have gone through a
pandemic where we borrowed 400 billion
and spent on furlough schemes and other
things we're now boring about close to
100 billion to help people with their
energy bills this money has to come from
somewhere Ali we have run out of time
but just to mention we didn't get to it
and that was a Sunday Telegraph so John
Major has attacked the crown down as a
damaging and malicious fiction and a
barrel load of nonsense and this is the
forthcoming series to start next month
the suggestions that could damage the
king's reputation thank you both uh see
you in the next hour